this BMW m4 is a continuation of BMWs
legendary M sports vehicles BMW began
building these fiery racers some 30
years ago
now in its fifth installment the new m4
is a stunner
it comes with a carbon fiber roof
you
a real attention-getter our car tester
Ronnie laughs Texas BMW is known for
luxurious and comfortable vehicles but
they make the legendary M sports cars to
today Ronnie will be taking the m4 out
for a spin the import has superseded the
m3 coupe a launching a whole new BMW
series Ronnie wants to find out whether
this m4 with its 6-cylinder biturbo
engine is a real BMW M
[Music]
this Beamer is a serious competitor in
its segment we selected an m4 with an
additional seven thousand three hundred
euro M Performance Package boosting its
output 2 331 kilowatts and propelling it
to 100 kilometers an hour in only four
seconds that's almost as fast as the
much costlier porsche carrera 4s the m4s
overall system has been adjusted to the
extra power and to top it off there's an
M sports exhaust system that's
highlights one Ronnie says the real
highlight of the m4 performance package
isn't the delightfully loud exhaust
system but the carbon ceramic brakes
they bring the car to an almost instant
standstill which feels like getting a
wall for that you've really gotta step
on it though and the brakes need to warm
up first but then they really deliver
once my convo position 16 however it's
the exhaust systems roar that's most
satisfying where that sound you don't
even have to speed and yet the vehicles
maximum torque of 550 Newton metres
makes it really tempting to press the
gas pedal
[Music]
MPs Ronnie says this m4 is really just
an m3 coupe a and that in his opinion
the m3 has always been a six-cylinder
engine candidate BMW first launched the
m3 with a four-cylinder engine then they
began making six-cylinder engines after
which they installed v8 engines now BMW
has returned to their standard biturbo
six-cylinder engines that gives the
vehicle a proper boost and increases its
torque transforming this Beamer into a
real powerhouse enhanced edition of 50
ml and three moment on dollars on glow
blush and manga boys took scuffed
[Music]
the racers interior is fitted with
high-end materials and a carbon trim as
if added trim could significantly reduce
the car's weight
[Music]
the competition package even boasts
lightweight front seats Ronnie can't say
the m4 is a beast of an automobile but
honestly it's not exactly sluggish
either plus the rear-wheel drive an
active limited slip differential make it
easy to handle